tout ce qui tient bernard montiel par
exemple c'est quoi vous alors voilà
c'est une catastrophe
sincèrement je ne sais pas ce qui est
mais j'ai pas peur alors ouais bon les
pistes noires comment les invoquer un
gay 2e blague deuxième roland et je ne
sais pas m'arrêter donc en général mais
sincèrement je ne sais pas m'arrêter je
m'en fous quand on voit bien où je vois
se régaler avec les anecdotes du style
alors jacques osele parterre vraiment
pas m'arrêter donc voilà et c'est génial
des strophes j'attrapais l'impasse et
seule anecdote
oui bah oui raconte quant à pété dans
les noms mais sinon la dernière fois
dans la dernière fois la vraie anecdotes
l'anr fouet mais j'ose pas le raconter
c'était vraiment ridicule enterrer les
dialysés j'ai posé les ce qui est
évidemment vraiment comme dans les
bronzés tout est tombé à genoux et
j'étais ridicule et janka s'est tu ta
soirée tant qu est ce qu une eau non tu
le fais tout seul lot à gâteau foule
d'anecdotes au ski agathois là il ya au
niveau de la peau qu il ya eu un délire
là bas c'est laisser laurent ouais vous
avez beaucoup de volume là un moyen pas
trop non orient est lente et pis c'est
tout alors alors anecdote j'ai fait du
ski une seule fois dans ma vie c'est en
classe de neige en cm2 et donc il nous
répartissent par groupes de niveaux donc
moi je suis dans le aa b c d e f g et
j'étais dans le groupe c'est parce que
de prime abord on me dirait que je suis
assez sportif donc pourquoi pas
charmante vous la paix merci alors là
bas mais ça s'est très vite la chute à
l'arrachement bien ouais pas vraiment et
au fil de la semaine donc tout le monde
s'améliore match du groupe b à et moi
jean lassalle pour qu'ils ont créé un
groupe g parce que j'étais nul mais on
en a besoin
et moi alors je vais procéder autrement
est ce que quelqu'un a une bonne
anecdote que cela série poule
comme je ne skie pas d'accord ce n'est
jamais évident pour vous tout vous dire
je me suis je suis pas venu il longtemps
ici parce que je me suis blessé en
mettant mon pyjama
donc j'ai tout de suite
géraldine manier tient à moi j'adore
skier avec concentration de victoire je
lisais un bouquet non madame la mairesse
d'un garçon quand jane white ap séduit
il s'appelle arthur we are suède d'isère
l'eifel amoureuse de lui et j'étais allé
le voir pour le 31 et il n'attendait pas
donc il était un petit peu déçue de me
voyais à la télé francoeur et ce qui est
vraiment bien moi je suis il était
charmant village à brancher un mois chez
moi c'est un très bon niveau à 40 forte
en slalom ouais ouais
et en fait je suis sur la piste et je me
fait renverser par un ce parent par un
surfeur s'est pas et j'ai une fracture
du nez au non avec les kurdes et des
autres propres du nez ou salés ouest
c'est là et donc j'ai passé le tronc
tard avec un énorme plaque sur le visage
dur quoi c'est sarah jeter dereon
n'arrivent les allées tellement rue pour
décoller non vous a gagné bas on finira
par isabelle morini-bosc moi c'est que
ça arrive ou gilles et moi c'est j'ai
une petite vidéo avec mon anecdote c'est
quand on a fait la lutte avec jean
michel et jean luc lemoine dans tpm paix
au ski la dernière course avec les
valises dans la main que j'ai plongé
pour tenter de gagner tout ça c'est mon
plus beau souvenir de ce qui n'était pas
au ski quatuor on à la vidéo mais à
chaque fois c'était ça oui c'était la
vidéo allez on passe un maximum bonsoir
n'ont pas la langue de particulière je
n'ai jamais écrit
en revanche je suis né dans les beaux
gestes c'est tout un paradoxe j'avais dû
suivre il a hélas il y la saison là
ces photos de 2014
sachez 14 puis le pro de la luge
ah oui c'est ça suffisait moi vous avez
pas un truc ma rose qui n'ont jamais à
l'écouté mois jarre lui alors j'étais
avec mon 3 3e c'est sa troisième étoile
et à la 12e qui est arrivé non mais
alors pendant tes pmb fait du ski oui on
a fait une épreuve qui ressemblait un
peu à ce qu'on a plus qu'on pourra voir
dans le film d'ailleurs la deuxième
étoile
va t on faisait une des points il
fallait déterré un poteau et en fait on
avait les yeux bandés ont été guidés par
un pas par un camarade léger des images
regardez bien comment jean luc lemoine
courts les yeux bandés et en chaussures
de ski c'est très très drôle mais sao
foot c'est ça ouais quoi témoin qui dit
on s'en fout
j'ai approfondi mais dès l'arrivée
toutefois encore un bond sur l'apport
est dans le coma tandis que j'adore oui
jean michel non la mienne elle est un
peu mal odorantes malheureusement c'est
qu'on est pas on sait on paie maintenant
on avait plus il sort deux parties dans
le temps c'était des combinaisons bras
qui ont météo mais des mineurs pour la
mettre à quel âge j'avais des doutes 10
12 ans je sais qu'on va considérer les
vacances la bâloise alba on n'y avait
pas encore les années soixante dix mois
qui ont traqué les connais télésiège que
l'été et 6h
et voilà et du coup je fais le toi est
évidemment je demande aux professeurs
d'aller de nouvelles toilettes le temps
qu'il ya une autorisation autant que j
ai que je retire la combinaison
évidemment le pire arrive à azé ming
émailleront après appel pour partir donc
je remets tout comme ça et du coup je
repars sur les pc sur les télésièges et
dont au fur et à mesure il ya de moins
en moins de gens à côté de moi sur le
tsl j'étais amené tout seul est bon et
il nous a bien fait chier aussi très dur
très dur pour les jeunes ont tout fait
pour nous cette anecdote qui sera
souvenirs douloureux également un alors
vous alors à c'était en cas d'année
comme allant à l'horizon dans une
station qui s'appelle la mort qui à
terme est la morale plus du grand serre
alors ça passe
elle a l'air sympa cette station des
arts y est on arrivé j'étais j'arrivais
près de la zone herbeuse
et c'est peut-être pas une skieuse
exceptionnel faut bien le dire on a plus
de classe orma
j'ai cru je suis j'ai fait une espèce de
notre espèce d'en bas et je suis retombé
lourdement sur ce que je croyais être
une grosse pierre et ce n'était pas une
grosse pierre je vous jure des bottes
noires et non c'était un sanglier était
un sanglier qui était bêtement là près
de la zone herbeuse loin quatre magasins
répartis dans trois marcassins de il est
parti à toute vitesse je me suis
accroché à lui comme une conne donc l
esquive un côté le sanglier et moi comme
ça et qu'on en est arrivé en bas et un
gendarme qui a dit à le cochon en moins
est arrivé à bon port
maxence un voyage je vous jure que c'est
vrai et puis le évidemment le sanglier
parties d'un côté moi dans l'autre un
texto de purin là mais c'était très long
c'est fini vous mettez vous avez un air
bizarre et jamais un air bizarre parce
que il faisait tellement froid que
j'avais mis une chaufferette la sofres a
glissé et est allé à l'endroit où elles
auraient pu être littéralement au sens
propre
j'ai eu le feu au cul toute la journée
savamment basse et niki lauda pour le
voir